boa tarde eu gostaria de ver um
capitalismo mais consciente
gostaria de ver um capitalismo -
predatório gostaria de ver que cada vez
mais as empresas usassem seu modelo de
negócio para criar impacto social
imaginem vocês também
e é por isso que vocês estão aqui hoje
eu queria voltar um pouco no meu passado
no final da década de 90
eu estava fazendo entrevistas para
trabalhar em bancos de investimento uma
vez eu liguei para um amigo que tinha
aceito preciso aceitado para o banco de
investimento que eu sonhava trabalhar
para perguntar como é que a entrevista
que eu devia falar
parece que foi ontem ele falava fala que
você ama dinheiro fala que você está
disposto a acabar com essa namorada para
trabalhar no banco
se o cara quiser comprar seu sapato você
vende seu sapato na entrevista mas falou
que o dinheiro a coisa mais importante
na sua vida
tive que fazer aquele personagem para
ser aceito no banco de investimento nos
últimos 15 anos eu trabalhei em banco de
investimento
não me arrependo sem ter trabalhado no
banco de investimento eu não teria
conseguido juntar dinheiro para realizar
um sonho era fazer o rali paris dacar no
país dacca
eu aprendi então quão importante é a
gente ser positivo na vida e aprendiz é
uma pessoa mais resiliente
fui também buscar uma espiritualidade na
índia
freqüentando os cursos da arte de viver
foram vários dias em silêncio só
meditando tentando se conectar comigo
o mercado financeiro também não teria
conseguido juntar dinheiro
para fazer uma pós graduação na
universidade de harvard e
empreendedorismo
mas foi lá que eu tive um professor que
perguntou para mim que você quer falar
pro teu filho quando ele tiver 15 anos
em relação à sua história profissional
ali eu já tinha uma família sendo
estabelecida tinham diploma das melhores
universidades do mundo tinha feito uma
das melhores
uma das provas mais difíceis mas não
sentia realizado profissionalmente e
resolvi fundar uma empresa
uma empresa foi batizada de avant e
nasceu com a missão de humanizar o
serviço financeiro devem estar
perguntando que é humanizar o serviço
financeiro é fazer completamente
diferente do que o mundo vem fazendo
hoje
a primeira coisa é colocar o cliente em
primeiro lugar o cliente
ele tem que ser mais importante do que o
acionista mães ao serviço financeiro
entender que o crédito não é uma ciência
exata
é uma fórmula matemática aquela pessoa
que está pedindo crédito e crédito
ela tem valores a tem uma história de
vida a ter uma rede de pessoas que
confiam nela e tem motivo para confiar
humanizar o serviço financeiro a gente
misturar uma equação humana como equação
exata já devem estar imaginando uma
empresa super bem intencionada um
currículo exemplar
a empresa nasceu num certo essa pessoa
nasceu num certo não empreender é sair
da zona de conforto
12 anos só tomando pancada
é muito difícil convencer meus amigos a
trabalhar comigo acreditar naquele sonho
mais difícil ainda convencer o
investidor investir na nossa empresa
eu estava bancando a empresa com
recursos próprios mas o dia e se
recusaram a acabar mas não um sonho
chegou um ponto que eu comecei a entrar
em desespero
eu fui fazer uma reunião no rio
mora em são paulo há obviamente eu fui
de carro porque a empresa não tinha como
pagar uma passagem de avião e eu fui
falar com a cufa central única das
favelas que tinha acabado de fazer uma
empresa que batizaram de favela holguín
que tinha a missão de levar à
empregabilidade emprego e
empreendedorismo para as novas favelas
brasileiras porque novas porque era uma
foto completamente diferente do que há
10 ou 15 anos atrás
a favela já podia ser um estado o quinto
maior estado do brasil
a favela já consumia 63 bilhões de reais
por ano e as pessoas ainda não
acreditávamos nos favelado
a gente tinha mil favelas e apenas três
agências de banco
eu fui conversar com o fundador da cufa
celso athayde que ele recebeu foi o
galdino um dos braços direitos deles
vamos ser hipócritas
apesar de ser uma pessoa vencedor ele
não tem cara de bonzinho
foram 15 minutos falando do que eu
acreditava que a gente podia fazer e a
cara deles era mais ou menos assim eles
não piscavam não sorriam eu começando a
ficar desesperado
será que estou agradando esses caras
será que estão entendendo que eu tô
falando
mas a reunião foi um sucesso a gente
saiu dali cada um com uma aliança no
dedo e o compromisso de amadurecer essa
idéia
vocês terem uma idéia eu estava tão
desesperado que ninguém acreditava no
que eu acreditava antes da reunião que
quando eu passei pela vale basílica
nossa senhora de aparecida
eu juro que eu cogitei eu vou parar aqui
vou fazer a promessa na volta a ser
batido nem via basílica só estava
pensando como é que eu ia abraçar aquela
oportunidade junto com celso de levar
serviço financeiro para as favelas
o dinheiro já estava acabando o sonho
não resolvi tirar umas férias para
pensar como é que eu ia explorar essa
oportunidade dentro das favelas em um
livro a rádio things about rádio fins
disparado o melhor livro que eu já li
sobre empreendedorismo cara tomou muita
pancada mas ele venceu mentira que eu ia
ler no livro
parecia que vem aquela moça do gato
carro
esse cara sou eu vou mostrar o vídeo
agora que a indústria um pouco do que a
gente construiu junto aos moradores para
jogos moro aqui há 33 anos
dez anos da minha vida eu acabei
perdendo e paradas e águas como álcool
às drogas o crime o tráfico como era há
um ano atrás conheci avante
tive a oportunidade de mudar para o bem
nessa quando um cidadão de bem e
agradeço muito
olha o avante o meu presente de se ter
um 39 anos graças a deus e que agora se
foi o primeiro presente de uma empresa
uma empresa que está me ajudando e
ajudando qualquer um se interessa
venha a nós e na nossa casa reconhece as
funções do ambiente a humildade do ponto
entendeu e todo começo é assim e lá na
frente você vê a beleza da humildade de
se controlar
bom talvez o edson não tivesse vindo
trabalhar com a gente voltaria atrás das
grades ou talvez juntar ia mais aqui
hoje conosco
hoje ele é uma pessoa que a gente
resgatou a dignidade dele de orgulho de
ver a filha dele o arnaldo cliente do
edson foi em todos os bancos pediu
empréstimo todos os bancos
o azul vermelho amarelo todo todo mundo
disse não pra ele
a gente acreditou e lhe ofereceu um
microcrédito
ele tem uma funilaria ele comprou as
ferramentas está a construir um forno e
agora vai começar a receber o serviço de
uma grande concessionária está pagando
todas as parcelas em dia
se você tem um sonho
o primeiro precisa pensar nesse sonho
vai realizar ele vai tomar pancada vai
ter que tentar de novo fazer de novo e
de novo fazendo você ter sucesso
eu só consegui ter sucesso porque eu sou
eu era maior do que só a vontade de
ganhar dinheiro porque foram muitas
noites mal dormidas
hoje é diferente quando eu comecei a
fazer entrevista em bancos de
investimento
eu acredito que os jovens vão forçar as
empresas a cada vez mais pregarem o
capitalismo só se em é consciente
os jovens vamos a cada vão forçar cada
vez mais as empresas usarem seus modelos
para criar impacto porque a empresa não
existe o que existe time e cultura
eu costumo falar o patrimônio ele vai
embora todo dia da empresa e volta no
dia seguinte que são as pessoas e hoje o
jovem ele não quer trabalhar em qualquer
tipo de empresa
eu tenho entrevistado bastante jovem as
entrevistas são completamente diferentes
quando eu fazia para entrar dentro de um
banco de investimento
o jovem hoje ele tem o poder de escolha
ele cada vez mais vai escolher aonde ele
quer trabalhar
as empresas que estão um capitalismo
tradicional na minha opinião estão com
os dias contados
vão ter que se reinventar eu queria
às vezes a gente fala de favela né há
ainda muito preconceito quando falo com
meus amigos
após a impressão de favelas está louco
né
eu queria falar uma frase do celso
athayde
como é que ele vê favela
nem perigo onde eu vejo emoção
eles vêm com paixão onde eu vejo ternura
eles vêm guerra onde eu vejo luta
eles vêm tragédia onde eu vejo a
oportunidade e se a favela só sabe quem
faz ou fez parte dela favela não se faz
safari se visita não se faz caridade se
solidariza o dia vocês vão saber como o
patrimônio mas só de uma favela
o ser humano não parece para alguns mas
há muitos humanos lá o primeiro
aprendizado que eu tive quando eu fui
pra favela foi entender que a missão do
empreendedor da favela é completamente
diferente da missão do empreendedor do
asfalto enquanto até a minha missão de
humanizar o serviço financeiro
a missão daquele microempreendedor a
inclusão social é levar a um futuro
melhor para a família dele acesso à
melhor saúde ensinam viagens tudo que a
gente faz o que a gente teve o mundo aos
nossos pés e é isso que eu quero
promover no eu queria convidar vocês
agora a gente fechar o olho por alguns
segundos ea gente um pouco para o futuro
meu filho está com 15 anos ea gente já
conseguiu impactar milhares de
microempreendedores atingirem sua missão
que vocês mandarem o máximo de energia
positiva aqui para o palco é meu sonho
amanhã é um novo dia
tenho certeza que seguirei lutando
fomentando e humanizando obrigado